and back then, on the day
I quit BMW, I met
my former boss in the country
canteen and
talked a little bit, hey, we want to
do Booking.com for containers here now
and that's going to be the big idea
and  He smiled at it a little bit at the time,
but said he had just
ordered a new fixie bike for his son from a Hamburg company,
bobbelo Hamburg company, they
definitely needed something like that, so I ran out of the
canteen and found the uh Sven
Hoffmann, the founder of borbelo, via
LinkedIn  written means if we have to
talk, a great
solution for you sent
his phone number a few hours later
and then I
worked for Halt for three months and then
two weeks after this conversation he
booked the first container with us